so we're thrilled to be hosting
Sebastian Faulks here this evening to
kick off our talks in English series so
thank you so much Bastion for coming my
project great to be here Frank so let's
kick off I mean to start with could you
tell us a little bit about your time
living living in France anecdote oh well
so many anecdotes I first visited France
when I was about 8 I went to do the
along the coast of Normandy with my
family we stayed in a funny old French
boarding house a bit like Mississippi
lose oliday
and I was rather than trance by that
especially by the fact that the taxi
that took us to the hotel is a sit one
dais which I play from my president of
girls Cup later on and I was growing up
they actually bought myself secondhand
in London
I came to Paris when I was 17 as a
student between school and university
and as about three months here very
lonely walking around the city but I got
to know the city quite well just on
first I couldn't afford to go anywhere
nice but I did go to lots of art
galleries and cinemas and so on and then
many years later my family by this time
I was a father with two small children
and we went to live in the southwest of
France near Asia and our children went
to the local village school and they did
Boyd learn to speak French very well
actually he's the first English person
I've heard speak French without an
English accent and he sounded completely
French yeah and the girl who was only
three she spent the afternoons with an
aunt mother and father and she could
speak French as well but with very very
strong southwestern eyes but anyway and
I come here on holiday most years I have
so many was at times at night okay and
any cultural differences that you could
think of take cultural differences
between Britain and France enormous I
mean just amazing one of the things I
like about France I think that what I
like best about it is that it's so close
to Britain 19 20 20 miles of the closest
and yet so entirely different really in
the way everyone here thinks about their
country themselves their life and
- - almost everything's different and I
don't think that France is better of
things and I think Britain as Bachelor
of things but I think that the
differences are already interesting
actually starting with you know the idea
of a party of father lines and we know
what that means to a French person
wouldn't be to a British person and then
right down to sort of personal behavior
and eating and how you live your life
yeah absolutely and do you think
speaking another language makes a
difference to the art of writing and
storytelling speaking another language
just has to be a good thing to do
because it opens doors you know I just
talking about the big differences
between France and Britain and if you
can speak the language you know begin
you start to get closer to of the
heartbeat of the people and the country
whether it makes a difference to how you
actually write I'm not sure because
writing in your own language the
composition of your own language but I
suppose having studied French grammar
which I did at school you know what -
quoi - a level no endless verbs and
tenses and so on
it gave me a deeper understanding of
grammar and how language works and in an
indirect way I suppose death has come
back into the way I write in English
yeah I think you're probably gonna be
touching on this later but some could
you tell us a little bit about the your
creative processes in writing well I I
wish there was an easy answer about the
creative process this can happen in
history and I think like most writers I
spend most of my time as a sort of
hunter researcher I'm a bit like Captain
Ahab on the [ __ ] looking for though the
big white whale out there somewhere I'm
searching for an idea for a story
combination of ideas which are going to
really interest me
sustain my interest over two years or
three years it takes and of course above
will bring the reader in and
unfortunately it's not just one like a
moment
you can writer a thriller or an airport
book on on a one-bite bomb and two twins
separated at birth you know meet again
right you know yeah but the kind of book
I tried to write which is a little bit
more ambitious than that no you need a a
number of ideas and they need to fit
together and once once I'm actually I
found what I want to do moment throes of
writing it's there that it's fine really
and then I just work at kind of nine to
five days right like working in an
office really and most writers I know
who are the same but if I write a so
then I would write a thousand words a
day perhaps and it sounds a lot but it
really isn't it's about three three
three pages and paper and if you know if
you were doing that every day of the
year that you'd be writing three books a
year right so that gives you as you how
seldom what is actually in the process
of writing yeah today in fact is the
European day of languages and what do
you think the diversity of languages in
Europe brings to our continents a lot of
complications I suppose for people who
can't understand one another but through
languages I suppose we discover what we
have in comedy and the language in
Britain was anglo-saxon was a pretty
rough language with very little too
little means of self-expression until a
version of French arrived through the
Norman invasion and that enormous ly
enriched the English language which then
thanks to the normal invasion and then
later the whole of whole of the French
language coming in and with it Latin and
Greek anglo-saxon became Middle English
and then modern English which then
became this huge rapacious sort of all
sucking into itself kind of language
which took words from all over the world
and then became the biggest language in
the world I know more people speak
Mandarin Chinese but in terms of its
reach across countries and so in Europe
you know we
you see we can see the roots of our
language and we can see how all the
countries are related through the
movements of history of what they've
taken from one another but of course you
know it is it's complicated for a
Bulgarian or a Romanian who arrives with
the movement of people into France or or
it's Britain they they don't speak the
lingo and the system and last question
how do you think that the franco-british
literature landscape or relationship
will be impacted by the exit well the
the truth is that there is not an
enormous exchange in literature between
well there is a big exchange between
France and Britain but it's very patchy
the authors that are translated from
English into a depression not
necessarily authors that we would choose
and we were quite surprised by French
taste it rehydrates really autism people
we think is likely right our teachers
are quite popular here and so on and
vice versa
you know pitifully few French ones
really are translated and when they are
late they're translated in small numbers
and so on and so forth and that is a
it's part of the way that we literary
cultures of the two countries are
extremely different and have developed
in different ways partly for quite
doctrinaire reason us political reasons
but I think that after brexit there will
be a big new effort among universities
research places and what you might call
the literary world yeah to do much more
together okay I would much rather we we
stayed in the EU but it is quite a
cumbersome organization the EU is not a
really lovely organisation
really and I think being out of it would
be a big shock to Britain and I think
that people will make really certain
that we do keep culturally close
connections with France and all the
other countries in Europe and I think in
some ways it might have quite an
energizing effect and if we're not
getting funds from the EU for scientific
research
the Erasmus schemes all sorts of things
like that I think that certainly in
Britain there'll be a big individual
Enterprise Drive to try and find other
ways of planting these things so you
know oddly enough we may have become a
bit lazy and maybe I'm gonna look on the
bright side here obviously I'm very
unhappy about brexit but looking on the
bright side I think it might have to
system unis okay well thanks very much
indeed your time especially very much